buenas tardes
como ya dijeron mi nombre es facundo
duarte y le vengo a hablar de la matiné
que la matiné la matriz por lo general
es un espacio que nos propone nuestro
liceo natural para cada día antes de las
vacaciones de julio de septiembre y la
de fin de año tener un espacio para
compartir con amigos
para hablar para comer como y para
bailar como lo hace la mayoría pero hay
casos especiales como el mío que no sé
bueno bailando y no disfruto de eso por
lo tanto prefiero centrarme en la barra
y con una mesa y compartir de una buena
pizza son una buena bebidas que es lo
que verdadera pasión
cómo comenzó esto
yo venía de una escuela diferente con mi
hermana o sea que entramos al liceo y no
conocíamos absolutamente a nadie es esa
situación vieron cuando cambian de un
lugar a otro dicen con quien hablo que
hago a dónde voy bueno al principio como
supongo que le pasará a todos los que se
cambian una institución a otra les
cuesta relacionarse va haciendo algunas
amistades unos conocidos y empieza más o
menos a hablar ya ya tener unos
encuentros y con intercambiar ideas
llegaron más o menos a mitad de año en
las vacaciones de julio y yo sentía que
había hecho son las amistades pero no
había profundizado como yo quería
tampoco había encontrado el momento
ideal para profundizar esas amistades
mi hermana y yo que como ya dije venimos
a diferente lugar somos exactamente
iguales diría yo solamente que ella con
ella con pelo y yo no bueno o más largos
o algo así
a nosotros dos se nos ocurrió una noche
del año 2015 probar esta situación que
nos proponía elíseo la matiné
al principio dijimos vamos a la matiné o
nos quedamos en casa preparando las
cosas para irnos de vacaciones y dijimos
por qué no y fuimos probamos la matiné
yo ya conocía a una de las personas que
estaba ahí que compartía exactamente los
mismos gustos que yo que era la comida
estábamos toda la noche comiendo toda la
noche no no no no teníamos ni un paso
solo comer comer y tomar esa persona es
santiago pastorino
lo conocí verdaderamente esa noche era
compañero de clase pero más bien era
santiago pastor y no número tal que
hacíamos algunos trabajos juntos pero no
pasaba de eso
esa noche puede conocer verdaderamente
lo que es su esencia de personas eso que
te hace impulsar a lograr una amistad
una relación más allá de compañeros como
él tuvieron unos tantos como un ejemplo
y nace formento que está allá arriba
acompañándome en todo
y unos tantos más
la matiné por lo general la matiné la
prepara la generación de cuartos la cual
está compuesta por unas 90 personas pero
no todos participan sino que aquellas
personas que están interesadas se
incluyen y partir y practican que hacer
este año se arme un arma un nuevo grupo
el cual llamó work que es trabajo
cooperativo que se ayudan mutuamente se
le había dado la idea de en ese grupo
hacer lo que quieran tipo dedicar ese
tiempo para hacer algo productivo que no
se les ocurrió hacer la máquina
nosotros a lo largo de los años hasta
llegar a cuartos pasamos por tres
mastines
pero en especial mío y otros veías que
faltaba algunas cosas
decías falta algo tipo a los que no les
gusta bailar a los que no les gusta
comer que hacen directamente lo hagan no
entonces nosotros en base a las
experiencias vividas
hicimos eso revolucionamos la matiné le
agregamos un espacio cuando se utilizaba
hicimos algo que se llama el pub
es que consiste el pago es un lugar
fuera de la música en la cual la gente
baila y eso es un lugar retirado donde
puedes estar jugar a las cartas con
amigos comer escuchar una música más
tranquila algunos que se destaque si
quieres puedes tocar el piano un
instrumento jugar el ping-pong y pasar
esos momentos
pero en la matiné en sí consiste
solamente en ese rato que uno pasa y en
lo que disfruta o va más allá de eso
eso es lo que nos pusimos a pensar al
intentar proponerles a ustedes
a nosotros al ver la gente que iba a la
matiné vimos las relaciones que se
formaban y cómo se rompía el hielo con
por ejemplo un profesor que vuelo
bebidas y decía para esto me manda tarea
no me deja nada libre o tremendo botones
pensados no y bueno voy a hacer la
matiné y decís nada que ver
por ejemplo nuestro su director eduardo
romero ahora nuestro director ahí
compartiendo con los ex alumnos esas
relaciones que uno diría que van más
allá del aula que se sigue manteniendo
ese respeto al alumno profesor alumnos
su director pero genera una relación
humana más allá de ese vínculo de
estudiante profesor y eso es lo que
queremos proponer nosotros a ustedes que
impulsen en sus liceos en sus escuelas
tener una oportunidad de compartir tanto
con los alumnos como sus educadores
animadores este espacio para poder
disfrutar pasar el tiempo y aprovecharlo
no pasar y ver como tu vida pasa tirar
una cama mirando una serie sino hacer
las relaciones que eso es para lo que
estamos viviendo
no sólo quedarse con eso también sino la
cierta confianza que genera las familias
a eliseo esa confianza que dice yo mando
a mi hijo y estoy tranquilo no tengo
conciencia sino que sé que en ese lugar
él va a estar bien con persona de la
institución sin ninguna droga sin ningún
vicio sino más callada que disfrutar de
lo extremadamente natural así que le
propongo a todos ustedes llevar y poder
lograr estas instancias en sus
instituciones gracias
[Aplausos]